Ready, but what am I supposed to do? I don't have to do anything. Right.
This is Radiolab. I'm Jad up. I'm Ron and I'm Robert Krulwich.
And today we're talking about aging. Yep.
Thank you ever wonder why it is that that human beings live. Um,
like what, how long do we live? About 70 years roughly. Something like that.
Yeah.
So why 70 as opposed to seven or like 700?
[inaudible] why that number? Well, that's, no,
that's a good question because every,
apparently every creature has for some reason a sort of natural range.
So you want to hear very cool one. Um,
how about a rat got a rat in your head
and a squirrel? The rat in the squirrel here you have two animals. People call.
Oh, I have friends who call squirrels tree rats.
That's Cynthia Kenyon from the University of California, San Francisco.
I recently paid her a visit.
You know, th some of the ways they're very similar to each other.
They're rodents, but a rat has a three year lifespan,
whereas a squirrel has a 25 year lifespan
and no one knows why. Really? There are theories, but no one really knows why.
I got the idea that maybe somehow lifespan was evolvable in the sense that there
might be genes in the animal,
which when change allow big leaps in lifespan to take place.
We figured that you could just hunt the genes down. Exactly,
and this is exactly what she seems to have done,
but not with rats and squirrels. What did I show you?
The incubator where we keep all the worms. Little roundworms, yes,
called the c elegans. Actually you can't see them with a naked eye.
They're just a little speck. But when you put them under a microscope,
you see how beautiful they are.
So first I'm showing you here the normal warm when it's a young adult and what
you can see is it's very active and it's healthy looking all the way in the
dishes as Wharton's looking great. Moving from that, it's a wiggle.
It was really nicely. Okay,
now let's fast forward two weeks.
Then she showed us eight different set of words in a different day.
These worms were 13 days, day 13 of adulthood.
They only live to 14 just live two weeks here at the very,
very end of their lives. And what we see here as a dead one,
so one has already died and another one that's clearly in the nursing home,
just lying, still not moving at all. And you can tell immediately that it's old,
it looks kind of wrinkled and lethargic and even if you've never seen a worm
ever, you can tell that one is old. So there you go. You've got a young worm,
you have an old woman.
Essentially what Cynthia Kenyon is trying to do is she's trying to hunt down the
gene that could turn that old worm backwards in time and make it look like a
young word. The worms have about 20,000 genes. So the idea is really simple.
You just go and change genes at random one by one,
one at a time and see whether any of these gene changes can extend life span.
How long did it take you to bump into a good one? Well,
we actually were lucky to find a gene pretty quickly and we found that if we
change this one gene called Daf too,
if we change this one gene called Daf too,
then the worms live twice as long as as they normally do,
just like pretty much by sheer luck,
she taken this worm and stretched lifespan for 14 days all the way out to about
28 days. Just 28 yeah. It doesn't sound like a lot to you,
but to where I'm next
[inaudible] wait, can you tell me like w w when you ran into it,
did you do like a little war dance around the laboratory? Where you at? Yeah,
it was amazing. I mean it was incredible.
I had a person in my lab who said deaf too is magic and she's right.
Okay. I'm going to show you these magic worms,
which are exactly the same as the normal worms,
except that we've changed one gene, the def two gene,
so remember that old wrinkly worm that we saw before? Yeah.
The whim she's about to show me is the same age as that 13 day old.
Were you the old way. Okay. And it's bolting out of,
it's bolting into the picture here. It looks young, it's moving.
It's very healthy. It's active. And actually if you take a microscope,
then you look at the tissues,
what you see as the tissues of the warm look young.
If you just look at that,
you just sit there and you just look at it and look at it and look at it and
just let it sink in. What it means. It's really amazing.
It's really a very deep and fundamental.
You're looking at something that I guess wasn't supposed to happen in some funny
way. There was supposed to die.
No,
sure. What exactly is this gene doing to make them live longer? Well,
maybe we should ask,
ask the question a different way because the worms that lived longer,
they didn't actually have this working gene. Right?
When we make a mutation in the Daf two gene,
we damage it and that actually causes it not to work as well.
So that actually is kind of profound.
That tells you right away that the worm has a gene in it.
That's shortening the warms lifespan,
which is why she calls it the grim reaper,
the grim reaper gene. It's the gene that makes you die
if you're aware. Right? So by damaging this gene,
Cynthia and her team essentially are taking the grim reaper
and knocking his knees out and stop that. Okay,
so the question is what exactly is the def to doing to make the cell age more
quickly? Here's where the story gets a little weird.
Well, we found another gene whose name is also daft, but it's a different Daf.
It's called daft 60 and this is a gene whose normal function is to keep you
young.
It's like a fountain of Youth Change to the way that there was a grim he virgin
before, right? And now there's a fountain of youth genes.
That's what she discovered at inside the worms.
These genes are struggling with each other. Here's how it works. When it,
when a worm ages,
normally the death two receptor two kind of squashes the activity of deaf 16 it
turns it down.
[inaudible]
lukewarm ages. Okay.
So when you come along and you inhibit the activity of the def two receptor
outage, now you liberate daft 16 yeah, free.
It springs into action and it activates about a hundred genes
in the DNA.
These hundred genes each do a little tiny good thing for the cell and altogether
it makes the cell live twice as long.
[inaudible]
so let me just back up here. So there's the bay, there's the, there's the,
there's the bad gene, the gene that says, all right, everybody died.
But the way that it tells everybody dies,
it goes particularly over to this little guy over in the corner who's the good
guys who's repairing and protecting and fighting disease. And it says to it,
conks it on the head like some kind of three stooges things is you shut up.
Exactly. So if that good guy can stay vibrant,
then we are in the bowling game for a little while.
Exactly. Very good.
And you can get a lifespan that may increase save 100% like the one I mentioned
even longer, even threefold fold. How'd you do that? Well,
we found that the signals from the reproductive system affect aging.
It turns out Canyon and her team found that if you steal away some of the worms,
BB making powers, that alone makes them live longer if you do that.
So what we did,
and if you crippled the grim reaper genes and if you strengthen the fountain of
Youth Gene, the best possible change, we knew how to make,
well now we're talking,
we get incredibly healthy animals that are lived to be
six times
[inaudible]
on average, which would be like 500 years for a human and they're so healthy.
It's incredible. Okay,
so that would be like Ben Franklin is still being around playing go. It's yeah,
it would be, it's just blows your mind to think about it. Which by the way,
that doesn't mean that it will ever be possible in humans.
Then why do we turn it by the way, listening to this program, no,
she kind of has to say that because she's a scientist.
She doesn't know yet whether it affects us. Um, on the other hand,
she has started the company. Yes.
Elixir and the company is making a pill that it's a pill for people.
Interestingly, have you any notion of how much you could slow down the process?
Well, we don't know. You know,
we're just hoping that we can slow it down at all,
but just imagine used to be, people would talk about that,
but as the world of fairytales and fantasy and now it's sort of reopens the
quest for the found of youth in a new molecular way.
[inaudible]
how did the, wait a second though, what happens if she,
dare I say it succeeds with this little pill of hers.
Do we necessarily want a lot of 500 year old golfers hanging around not getting
out?
Oh, we were already there in, in some places in the world,
in Germany and in Japan,
the population of older people has grown to the point where you,
if you are in middle aged or younger person,
you'd feel the oppression of having so many people to support and to get worried
for a second. Japan might be a canary in the coal mine as it were.
Sort of a glimpse of where we're all headed. Jocelyn Ford,
a reporter has been looking at aging societies in Asia and recently took a trip
back to Japan where she used to live to see how they're dealing with things and
I arrived in Japan.
It was immediately obvious that that there was something different here.
I went into the closest little town to the airport and there was a [inaudible]
festival street festival going on. I
went down the street and what really surprised me is I think of street fairs and
kids playing and you know, let's go out with a family.
But everyone sitting around listening to the music was a lot of gray heads.
I met a guy who was like 90 years old and he was on a bicycle
and even when he cycled off, I felt it's a different society.
Bottom line is this job in Japan easing is very fast.
The fastest ever in the entire world. This guy banging the chocolate. Yeah,
that's humor. A little gala hero gala.
I'm a demographer at the New York University populace and Research Institute.
Where is that by the way? No. Is that in Tokyo and Tokyo?
And he said that the reason that Japan looked so old,
all of a sudden it's because in part people are living longer,
but that's not the big reason. The big reason is that the birth rate is falling,
the Japanese population is shrinking. They're not having as many kids already.
That's exactly it.
And this is something that's happening all over the developer world.
People are having smaller families and as a result,
there are fewer young people, more older people right now.
And in fact the proportion of the elderly men 65 and over is more than 21% which
is the highest anti world. 21% elderly. Can you imagine what that looks like?
No, just don't think Florida.
What do you think of when you think of Florida? Florida?
I think of beaches and I do. Well,
that's where a lot of old folks go to retire. So I think it's of a lot of,
you know, 70 80 year olds, Florida is the oldest state in the United States,
but compared to Japan,
it's young.
It's only 17% over 65 and Japan is 21% whoa.
So imagine that all of Japan looks like Florida,
just older and OCO expects that percentage to double in 40 years. Oh,
right now. I mean, can I read a picture? The future scenario,
but it's going to change.
I got some insight into that change back at the street fair.
I went to get some tea and rice crackers. I in that shop,
there was 103 [inaudible]. Granted I tried to talk to her,
but she couldn't really communicate, but
she didn't, I don't
really know what was going on. Nanny,
her daughter who's in her sixties is the main caretaker is 16 in her sixties and
she has to, the granny can no longer get out of her wheelchair by herself.
She can't take a bath. She's completely dependent on her daughter,
like a baby nanny,
but she's a lot heavier than a baby and who her daughter had really strained her
back and hurt herself.
The elder looking at me to the agent basically. And that's probably the biggest,
the biggest [inaudible]
problem. The problem is that the caregivers,
a primary of the caregivers is about forties and 50s so we are sort of short on
caregiver.
That never occurred to me that from society's perspective,
the reason kids are are good or useful is so that they take care of the old
people. Yeah. That government spokesman I spoke with,
thank you so much for making this tiny Gucci [inaudible].
He was quite concerned about about that.
There's going to be a shortage of labor as society ages and someone has got to
fill the void in countries like the United States.
We might import foreign labor. Sure. Meaning immigrants care for the elderly,
you know, but in Japan it'll happen only reluctantly,
not so simple because this society is still debating whether it's going gonna be
a good thing or not to increase in library immigrants.
We have decided to open our labor market to some extent.
Nishimura yes, please. Another government spokesman forest,
we have started said the government has decided they can allow me more than 100
hundred Filipino being caregivers to come into the country.
Just a hundred just a hundred huh? I know what you're thinking. Is it basically,
is it basically because Japan is, you know, phobic
well, um, let's put it this way.
Japanese people tend to
have this island concept.
Having more international workers in our neighborhood might die. Dude,
that kind of tradition.
I think that's what the Japanese people might be worried about.
What's wrong with that? Things change. I think basically communication,
particularly when he's sick. I mean when you're bedridden,
if the nurses are foreign foreigners, then you have to communicate.
It's very difficult.
You know, some people might think that's Xeno phobic,
that people don't don't want to deal with foreigners,
but that's not really what it's about.
People don't want to be a burden to anybody.
They don't want to depend on anybody. I don't want to
have the same burden. If you say this is Mr Suga,
he's a demographic researcher. You just don't want to be a burden. No.
This feeling that you shouldn't be a burden. It runs very deep physically,
psychologically, a boss of them.
I just prefer I will be helped not by any other people.
Why is that? Just a feeling.
It might cause problems with them, with other people.
So you'd be more comfortable knowing that you're not putting anyone else causing
them trouble.
Yup. Yup, Yup, Yup.
So if I will need some help from other people,
I might want to kill myself. That's how extreme it gets.
This is a young man who's 30.
He said I would rather commit suicide than be taken care of by somebody who
doesn't want to take care of me. Who, who I'd be a burden on. You know. Uh,
there is a culture like two, 300 years ago in Japan,
if the old Walmarts a life until like six 70 years old,
then, uh, family take this,
this old mothers to a mountain and so
stay there. Make that my best date. Yeah.
It's a very long tradition in Japan of they call it at Oh boss
[inaudible] Obamian is it grandma and stamens too to throw up,
throw away your serious, they have whole movies about this in Japan.
[inaudible] there's one called [inaudible]
the ballot of Nakayama. It's second, a very poor rural village.
About a hundred years ago.
The story of a son, his old mother up the mountain
on the way up, they pass by another son,
literally killing his father off of a cliff.
[inaudible]
it makes a family happier.
So grandma's stays in the mountain and starves to death.
The family is happier because there's less of a burden, right?
It was understood among all the generations.
This was the way the problem was solved.
Not Anymore, obviously. Right? Right.
In Japan is really quite socialist these days.
They look after everyone in society, but that idea is still out there.
So what do you do today? You don't want your kids to take care of you.
You don't want foreigners to take care of you. Who's left? Well,
one solution is instead of having people do these jobs have machines,
machines, robots, robots,
you joking. It's not actually a joke. Um,
Panasonic and others are manufacturing robots. As a
caregivers, when you think about it, it sort of makes sense.
Why don't we automate the heavy duty [inaudible]
welcome to meet Ali. They did a bunch of labs and met with some scientists.
This Robert, it's connected to here. They've got robots that will,
it looks like a dentist chair or your wheelchair,
where to go and how fast this is going. There's a special pair of trousers
that you can put on and if your legs are weak and you can't walk well,
it will help you walk. There's a washing machine robot.
It looks like it's got a fancy handle.
It's actually for washing people or any of these natural use. Yes, they are.
Will do not want to have to ask somebody to clean their diapers to wash their
bum. Right. I think for anybody in any society,
that is a difficult thing to have to ask somebody robots up more. I mean, don't,
you don't have to talk. You just press a button. Now.
This is where I start to get weirded out.
I went to a nursing home about an hour and a half outside of Tokyo
[inaudible] people must be sitting around.
There's a television about three people are watching the TV.
One's looking out the window.
I walked in and there were a lot of old people just sitting around each keeping
mostly to themselves, sitting very quietly,
not talking. It was sort of sad in steps.
Pero the seal
pro is one of the world's first therapy robots get it? No.
What does that mean?
What they've done is they've made this sort of like a large stuffed animal,
white, furry, long eyelashes and flutters them at you and it squeals.
When Paul came out, one of the grantees just lit up,
got so excited.
She peered into the seals eyes and she tried to talk to it
to come the
same feeling that when family come here,
I was taken back.
I mean it's not much more than a moving stuffed animal and how could you look at
it and see companies see something alive? It's something comforting,
feeling a little bit warm. It's Pero warm temperature control.
I spoke to the developer, Mr [inaudible], so you're warm blooded, Huh?
He said, yeah.
They wanted a creature that would give them positive feedback but also sort of
made them good for puddle,
so of tried to be stroked by the owner like you're doing right now.
You program to want to be home held.
He also programmed them to respond to different names. For example,
by call him as part of a new name like John or something,
or like Chaco Channel and called the new name again. Again,
gradually learn the new name and start the response
so it's learning you down carefully because we don't want to hurt you. Oh,
you want to be held again. They learn from their environment.
Now these are really rudimentary, you know, beginning baby robots,
but it worked, Jed, it worked.
They adored it. They were loving it and it was loving them in their minds.
I started to think maybe this is a solution.
People might actually be able to engineer compassion, engineer, companionship.
But then I started asking a lot of people around me.
It took an informal Straw poll.
Would you feel comfortable with a robot taking care of you?
And most people said, no, not really.
[inaudible] like this woman, Keiko Sugi,
she actually came up with a brilliant idea, which seems like a no brainer.
She has a nursing home,
which is together with a preschool. So we'd actually you to take a tour.
You walked into the room and you are bombarded by these little parties flying
around. It's just over the top.
Well,
and it's expensive. And if you are an old person in that environment,
you have no time whatsoever to dwell on
the idea that you are dying.
The kids are, they demand your attention, but you need, you
need it again. But the first thing that you told us,
the very beginning is that they're more old folks, less kids. Well,
what happens when these kids we're listening to right now when they tondo
there's just a bunch of old people around and there's gonna be one kid left and
they all go to visit that one kid.
I mean that that can't work and you expect me to have an answer will be we
should import kids. I don't know. No, I mean you're joking obviously,
but when I guess what I'm asking is like w are we left at the end just to,
to think that this society cannot support all of its members getting old.
That somehow the old have to step out of the way that I think you're thinking is
basically old fashioned. They will be more old people and fewer young people.
That's a fact. You're not going to turn the clock back on this.
Societies do change. People do come up with new ideas and right now, hey,
they're stabbing in the dark after them.
But one day they'll come up with a solution. So learn to deal with it.
Tammy, you just bitch slap me.
You call me all the way across the Pacific Ocean, across the whole continent.
Break now, cause they've got to sort of pick up my ego.